en ce mois de janvier 2010 est où il est
de bon ton de prendre des résolutions et
bien je me suis pour prendre de bonnes
résolutions
d'abord faire un bilan savoir ses
faiblesses et ses forces et pour ça dit
chiffres qui vont marquer en 2016 ça me
paraît pas mal un pourcentage classement
mais pas de punch est en pourcent la
fraude sociale qui s'élève à 695
millions d'euros et dont on nous rabâche
les oreilles à longueur de temps en nous
parlant des gens qui fraudent pôle
emploi ou les allocations familiales
nous représentent au total qu'un petit
pourcent de la fraude fiscale en france
ll est comprise entre 60 et 80 milliards
2016 a été l'année du scandale des
panamas peppers jeu par revenir dessus
puisque je l' ai déjà fait lors d'une
vidéo que je vous remets en descriptions
mais ce scandale aura permis de remettre
un vrai coup de projecteur sur l'ampleur
du phénomène de l'évasion fiscale alors
j'y tiens particulièrement parce qu'on
entend parler toute l'année du terrible
problème de la fraude sociale en france
on dépense une énergie folle à dénoncer
cette fraude sociale et tout faire pour
l'éradiquer
quant à côté on entend très peu parler
de la fraude fiscale retenez donc bien
ce chiffre il est hyper important
surtout dans ce contexte de crise et
d'austérité
j'espère que les candidats à la future
présidentielle visiblement bien motivés
par l'idée de faire des milliards
d'économies ont bien noté dans leur
résolution de 2010 est de poursuivre la
lutte
pourquoi poursuivre parce qu'elle a déjà
commencé ça nous amène à notre second
chiffre qui est tombé en mars 2016 12,2
milliards d'euros c'est le montant total
des recettes encaissées grâce à la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale pour l'année
2015 parce qu'on peut critiquer le
mandat de françois hollande sur pas mal
de points
mais depuis 2013 avec à la fois le
renforcement de l'arsenal législatif 70
mesures en quatre ans et l'amélioration
des moyens qui sont consacrés on est
clairement montée d'un cran en matière
de lutte contre la fraude fiscale
ce montant de recettes et constitue lui
aussi un record 1 12,2 milliards c'est
ouf
et pour vous aider à mettre le chiffre
en perspective c'est plus que les
budgets de la justice de la culture et
de l'aide au développement
1,9 million c'est le nombre de personnes
au rsa en france en 2016 et c'est le
troisième chiffre tout à l'heure je
m'indigne et de l'énergie dégagée à
poursuivre à la fraude sociale avant de
s'occuper de la fraude fiscale et c'est
un problème qu'on rencontre pas mal
aujourd'hui
en fait nos médias parlent tellement de
certains sujets qu'on finit par se
persuader qu'ils doivent être
extrêmement important et le phénomène se
retrouve renforcé par le temps de parole
excessif
accorder à certains politiciens aux
idées bien arrêtées spéciale dédicace à
florent philippot ou à eric ciotti qui
sont pas loin d'être autant à la
télévision que ce rythme lorsqu'on les
écoute on pourrait facilement imaginer
qu'un bon quart de la population
bénéficie aujourd'hui du rsa alors qu'en
fait en 2016
c'est uniquement 2 88% de la population
qui en bénéficient et notre quatrième
chiffre est encore plus révélateur de ce
phénomène
7 5% la population française se dit
musulmane alors jusque là rien de fou
sauf qu'une étude ipsos mori publié en
décembre 2016 réalisé dans 40 pays et
intitulé les périls de la perception
révèle que tous les pays interrogés
or indonésie et turquie surestiment leur
nombre de musulmans à la france arrive
en tête de ce classement avec une
proportion de musulmans dans la
population estimée à 31 % 31 % au lieu
de 7,5
je me demande bien ce qui a pu
encourager les sondés à imaginer ça
tient et puisqu'on parle de classement
et de médias on arrive à notre cinquième
chiffres 45 alors pour le coup c'est
plutôt une position 1 45e sur 180 pays
dans le classement 2016 sur la liberté
de la presse
non seulement 45e c'est pas fou mais ce
qui compte c'est aussi la dynamique est
là ça pas non plus puisqu'on a perdu
sept places par rapport à 2015 à quoi
c'est dû à plusieurs facteurs un
attentat ton des journalistes ça peut
perdre des points des lois mises en
place dans la foulée qui a augmenté les
possibilités d'écouté et réduit la
liberté d'expression aussi et
l'appropriation de la presse française
par une poignée d'hommes d'affaires dont
les intérêts peuvent souvent plus que
leur attachement au journalisme parce
que entre les conflits d'intérêts une
situation financière qui nécessite
parfois de faire du sensationnalisme
avant de faire de l'information
on comprend peut être un peu mieux le
classement de la presse française et au
passage c'est pour ça que c'est
important de soutenir des émissions
comme ça le slip et comme le projet
global autour de la chaîne cyrus north
et je le dis en toute non objectivité et
le tipi et en descriptions mais ce
classement de la liberté de la presse
c'est pas le seul dans lequel on doit
chercher à s'améliorer en 2010 732 c'est
notre sixième chiffres et c'est aussi
notre classement sur 145 pays en matière
d'égalité salariale entre hommes et
femmes
selon le forum économique mondial c'est
vraiment pas fou et même si on est
classé 15e sur le classement global en
matière d'égalité femmes hommes c'est
incroyable de se dire qu'on puisse être
classés en 2016
aussi bas sur un critère comme celui ci
35 c'est notre septième chiffres c'est
encore une position c'est un petit côté
kama sutra oui on est 30
kane sur 37 ans les pays ocde en matière
d'inégalités scolaires dans le
classement publié en avril 2016 par
l'unicef
le fossé entre les performances des
élèves en fonction de leur milieu social
est très très important en france sur ce
critère on est des cancres depuis 16 ans
est un faux c'est qu'on ne comble pas en
16 ans c'est un cratère quoi juste pour
que vous puissiez y voir un peu plus
clair
le milieu socio économique explique plus
de 20 % de la performance obtenue par
les élèves de 15 ans contre 13 % en
moyenne dans l' ocde
seule la hongrie et le luxembourg se
situe également à un niveau supérieur
avant ton sang alors après c'est pas une
fatalité
les pays qui ont réussi à réduire cette
inégalité ont des profils vraiment varié
ça va du canada à l'estonie en passant
par le japon
alors pourquoi pas nous mille trois cent
pour cent
c'est notre huitième chypre et c'est le
pourcentage de croissance moyenne sur
ces quatre dernières années des start up
française selon le palmarès deloitte de
2016 et ouais mon gars
la veille france ce pays de grévistes
dans lequel personne ne travaille jamais
sauf entre deux jours fériés place 94
start up sur 500 dans ce palmarès qui
classe les startups européennes ayant la
plus forte croissance de chiffre
d'affaires
puis au passage ça nous place à la
première place du classement en tant que
pays puisque le royaume uni n'intègre
que 70 start up à ce palmarès et
l'allemagne 23
on apporte du positif à cette succession
de classement plutôt négatif
c'est franchement cool est plutôt
encourageant quant à l'avenir économique
de notre verte contrée en parlant de
vertes contrées il serait intéressant
qu'elles le restent et là dessus on part
tous ensemble découvrir notre autre oui
c'était le neuvième ses fruits il ya
encore quelqu'un qui suit 14%
c'est le pourcentage d'énergies
renouvelables qui a eu la france sur sa
consommation d'énergie en 2015 d'après
des chiffres qui ont été publiés en 2016
alors je rappelle qu'on doit atteindre
l'objectif de 23 % d'ici 2020 on a même
perdu trois places dans le dernier
classement et on est très loin derrière
la suède champion incontesté avec 52,1 %
d'énergies renouvelables alors on se
motive des lois ont été votées pour
corriger le tir dont la loi de la
transition énergétique et on rattrape
son retard en acceptant que le nucléaire
bien que fleurons énergétiques français
mais moi nobilise plus tous les
investissements du secteur
parce que bon son papier on a tout pour
réussir on est le pays organisateur de
la coop 21 on à nicolas hulot
on a même réussi à faire changer la
couleur de nos mac do et sans transition
énergétique
passons aux derniers chiffres de cette
vidéo sans aucun doute le plus
matic de 2016 180% art s'agit-il du
chiffre symbolisant la diminution du
nombre de mes cheveux entre l'avant et
l'après était 2016 non il s'agit de
l'augmentation du nombre d'inscription
en ligne sont in east électorale par
rapport aux dernières élections
six cent soixante mille personnes se
sont inscrites en ligne en 2016 contre
235 milles en 2011
c'est super cool notamment avec 50 % des
inscriptions qui ont lieu en décembre et
même sa eu des explications avancées par
la presse
je pense entre nous que c'est peut-être
ma dernière vidéo je m'avance pas mais
j'espère en tout cas que cette vidéo
vous a plu pour rappel shaqif chaque
chiffre pardon à sa propre méthode de
calcul son propre contexte
et tous peuvent être commentés et
discuter alors si vous voulez partager
le chiffre qui vous a le plus marqué en
n'hésitez pas la section commentaires
est là pour ça je fais de gros bisous je
vous souhaite une très bonne année je
les ai déjà fait mais je leur fais c'est
gratuit ça mange pas de pain c'est pas
comme les canards of peace et merci de
soutenir le projet merci à tous les
types heures merci beaucoup et j'ai des
réseaux sociaux aussi vous pourrez
retrouver sur réseaux sociaux facebook
twitter ce tom pyatt
voilà les canards venu comme ça